>> WE WILL GET BETTER GAME AFTER
GAME AFTER GAME AND PLAY SMARTER
AND PLAY BETTER, ALL RIGHT?
KEEP YOUR HEADS UP.
>> THAT WAS SHORT AND TO THE
POINT.
WHAT DO THEY HAVE TO DO BETTER?
>> FIRST OF ALL, ERNIE, ME AND
KENNY, WE TALKED ABOUT IT BEFORE
THE GAME.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT AT HALFTIME.
>> WE WILL TALK ABOUT IT NOW.
>> EVERY TIME THEY RUN A
PICK-AND-ROLL, THE CENTER IS
BELOW THE FREE-THROW LINE.
>> DO WE HAVE THAT PLAY?
>> SHOW ANY PLAY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SHOW A
PARTICULAR PLAY.
>> KENNY WANTS IT.
>> START IT OVER.
FREEZE IT HERE.
WE DON'T HAVE -- WE CAN'T SEE
WHERE BOBBY IS.
RIGHT NOW BOBBY PORTIS IS
ACTUALLY IN THE PAINT.
FREEZE IT THERE.
>> THAT IS NOT A PICK.
>> FREEZE IT THERE!
IF HE GETS LOST OR PICKED, TRAE
YOUNG IS WIDE OPEN.
IF I'M THE POINT GUARD AND I'M
JRUE HOLIDAY, NO WAY I CAN GUARD
A GUY DANCING.
AS THE PLAY DEVELOPS YOU'LL SEE
WHERE BOBBY PORTIS IS COMING
FROM.
FREEZE IT.
LOOK WHERE HE IS.
FREEZE IT THERE!
NO WAY.
JOHN COLLINS THAT HE COULD BE IN
THE PAINT THERE AND GUARD THE
MOST PROLIFIC SCORER SECOND TO
DEVIN BOOKER IN THE PLAYOFFS
THAT IS LEFT.
>> IF YOU WANT TO BE TECHNICAL
THAT IS NOT REALLY A PICK.
>> NO BUT YOU GOT TO GET AROUND
HIM, SHAQ.
>> LET ME SHOW YOU.
HE RECOVERED.
>> BUT HE DROPPED --
>> NO HELP.
THAT IS WHY HE IS JUMPING ALL
OVER AND PLAYING DOUBLE CUTS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THIS IS A
DEFENDER THAT YOU AND CHUCK WAS
BRAGGING ABOUT."
WAIT!
THEY SAID THEY SEND A PICK ON
HIM.
>> THAT AIN'T NO PICK!
HE GOT CROSSED UP.
STOP IT, CHUCK!
HE GOT CROSSED UP!
>> ANOTHER MAN THERE.
>> BRO, HE WENT UNDER.
>> HE IS AVOIDING A MAN.
>> HE WENT UNDER.
>> RIGHT BUT IF THERE IS HELP
THERE, SHAQ, IF -- I'M NOT
SAYING HE DIDN'T GET CROSSED UP.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
HOWEVER, HE IS AVOIDING SOMEONE.
IF YOU GOT TO AVOID SOMEONE AS A
POINT GUARD AND IF YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY KIND OF HELP, YOU ARE
GOING TO GET DANCED ON BY STEPH
CURRY AND DANCED ON BY TRAE
YOUNG AND PAUL GEORGE, DEVIN
BOOKER.
NONE OF THOSE GUYS I JUST NAMED
YOU CAN GUARD LIKE THAT.
THEY WILL GET 50 POINTS AND HE
HAD 48 TONIGHT.
>> THE BIG GUYS GOT TO BE IN THE
PICTURE.
THIS DUDE HAD TIME TO SHAKE,
SHIMMY, AND LINE UP, EVERYTHING.
BIG GUY IS USELESS.
>> HE IS AVOIDING THIS.
>> HE RECOVERED.
RIGHT THERE.
>> TRYING TO JUMP OVER THE PICK
BEFORE IT COMES BECAUSE THERE IS
NO HELP.
THERE IS NO HELP.
IF THEY DID THIS, IF CHUCKY
BROWN WAS MY 4 AND THOSE GUYS, I
WOULD JUST BE LIKE TAKE ME OUT
OF THE GAME I'M NOT DOING THIS
AND NOT I'M NOT PARTICIPATING IN
THIS.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE ME BE ON
THE ISLAND OUT HERE AND LET GUYS
RUNNING AT US.
THEY ARE HEAD HUNTING HIM.
>> YOU CAN PICK ANY OF THOSE
PLAYS.
LOPEZ HAD SEVEN POINTS AND ONE
REBOUND.
HE NOT MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
BACK UP EVERY TIME AND NOT
DOMINATE ON THE BOARDS, HE IS
USELESS.
SO PUT SOMEBODY OUT THERE SO
THEY CAN MAKE TRAE DO SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> ONLY THING YOU WOULD DO WHEN
YOU IF WERE UP THERE, SHAQ.
YOU USED TO DO THIS AND WE USED
TO SAY SHAQ IS DOING IT SO THEY
GO UNDER.
IF YOU'RE GUARDING HAKEEM YOU
ARE BUMPING HIM ON.
HE IS HEAD HUNTING AND JOHN
COLLINS, LET ME GET HIM.
NO.
HE HAS TO BE FIGHTING YOU AND
PUSHING OFF ON YOU.
>> ONE THING YOU'RE NOT TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION.
MAYBE TRAE IN CATEGORY YOU CAN'T
GUARD HIM ON PICK-AND-ROLL.
CAN I TALK?
>> NOT IF YOU'RE WRONG.
>> I'M NOT WRONG.
>> YOU'RE 100% WRONG.
CAN YOU STOP CHRIS PAUL IN
PICK-AND-ROLL?
>> NO.
YOU CAN MAKE DETERRING.
>> CAN YOU STOP HIM?
>> HE WAS NOT DEFERRED.
A DIFFERENCE.
>> CAN YOU STOP CHRIS PAUL?
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT STOPPING A
GUY.
>> CAN YOU STOP STEVE NASH?
DID YOU SLOW HIM DOWN?
>> YES.
YES, YOU CAN.
>> YES, YOU CAN.
>> BUT THAT WAY IS NOT GOING TO
DO ANYTHING.
>> LISTEN.
NO WAY IS GOING TO WORK.
>> OH, YES.
>> NOT TRUE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT STOPPING HIM.
IT'S ABOUT SLOWING HIM DOWN.
IF YOU DON'T LET HIM COME UP
EVERY TIME --
>> HE GOT 48 POINTS AND 11
ASSISTS.
>> JOHN COLLINS GOT A WIDE-O